when Muslims preach Islam to a Christian
they're quick to say we believe in Jesus
too in fact we love Jesus more than
Christians
do but when you start asking what they
mean by belief in Jesus it turns out to
have nothing to do with the Jesus who
walked the shores of the Sea of Galilee
they don't go to first century sources
to learn about Jesus they don't go to
historians to learn about Jesus they go
to muham to learn about Jesus Muhammad
simply told his followers without any
evidence whatsoever that many of the
most important people who came before
him were Muslims even though we know
historically that they weren't Muslims
at all so when our Muslim friends claim
we believe in so and so who came before
Muhammad all they really mean is we
believe whatever Muhammad said about so
and so we believe in Muhammad and in
Muhammad's version of so and so that
Muhammad came up with when he stole so
and so from so and so's real
followers it seems that Muhammad robbed
more than Caravans my friends he also
robbed religions he took the most
popular religious figures from Jews and
Christians just like he took the cabba
and the Hajj rituals from the
polytheists of Mecca when Muhammad
wanted something he took it and said
that Allah wanted him to have it just
ask Aisha now if you show a Muslim
preacher that all of our historical
sources not to mention every respected
historical Jesus scholar on the planet
contradict the Islamic view of Jesus
you're sure to get a thoughtful
carefully researched
response oh did I say thoughtful
carefully researched response I meant
you're sure to get an absurd possibly
insane conspiracy theory why does all of
history contradict the Islamic view of
Jesus because someone corrupted all of
history well who corrupted it if you're
talking to a Muslim who knows absolutely
nothing about history you'll hear
something about the Council of NAA or
Constantine in the 4th Century but if
you're talking to a Muslim who knows
anything whatsoever about history he'll
know that belief in Jesus death
resurrection and deity can all be traced
back to the first century so he'll need
to give you a conspiracy theory about
the first century and that's when he'll
tell you that the Apostle Paul corrupted
Christianity of course the idea that
someone could destroy Jesus message
should sound strange whether you're a
Christian or a Muslim according to both
Christianity and Islam Jesus lived the
most miraculous life in history which
means that his work and message must
have been pretty important to God but it
was all a waste of time according to
Muslims because no matter how hard he
tried Allah just couldn't protect Jesus
message from the mighty Apostle Paul in
sorah 3:55 of the Quran Allah promised
Jesus that he would protect Jesus
followers until the day of
Resurrection behold God said oh Jesus I
will take thee and raise thee to myself
and clear thee of the falsehoods of
those who blaspheme I will make those
who follow thee Superior to those who
reject Faith to the day of Resurrection
then shall ye all return unto me and I
will judge between you of the matters
wherein ye dispute in Surah
61:4 Allah says that he aided the true
followers of Jesus until they became
uppermost over those who opposed Jesus
Oh you who believe be helpers in the
cause of Allah as Isa son of miam said
to his disciples who are my helpers in
the cause of Allah the disciples said we
are helpers in the cause of Allah so a
party of the children of Israel believed
and another party disbelieved then we
aided those who believed against their
enemy and they became
uppermost so Allah thought he could
protect Jesus message he promised Jesus
that he would make Jesus followers
Superior to those who reject Faith to
the day of Resurrection that's a long
time and Allah said that he did it he
said that he aided the true followers of
Jesus until they became uppermost over
those who rejected Jesus but according
to our Muslim friends Allah just wasn't
prepared for the Apostle Paul the
Apostle Paul completely overpowered
Allah fored Allah's plans and even
tricked Allah into aiding the wrong
followers poor
Allah our Muslim friends just don't see
a problem with believing in someone
Jesus whose message totally contradicts
Islam so long as they can magically wave
away all available evidence with their
conspiracy
wand how can we get them to understand
how silly this
is I know let's do the same thing to
Muhammad let's approach Muhammad
the same way Muslims approach Jesus or
Moses or Abraham here goes let me
announce here and now that I believe in
Muhammad I believe that Muhammad was a
true Prophet I'm sure Muslims will be
thrilled to hear this and they'll
respond that's great David so you agree
with us that Islam is true no no I don't
you see the Muhammad you Muslims believe
in is is a
corruption I believe in the true
Muhammad who was a devout Christian sent
to preached the gospel to the Arabs
Muhammad was convinced that God is a
trinity and that Jesus is the Divine son
who entered creation died on the cross
for sins and rose from the dead now you
may be wondering if Muhammad was a
devout Christian why do Islam's most
trusted sources say that he preached is
Islam and rejected the Trinity and
rejected the deity of Christ and called
for the violent subjugation of
Christians I'm glad you asked I'll tell
you what
happened before the time of Muhammad
most of the Christians in Arabia were
Heretics and
compromisers Muhammad came to restore
true faith in Jesus Christ he spent his
entire life telling people to repent and
to accept Jesus as their lord and savior
and to believe that God is one in
essence but three in person Father Son
and Holy
Spirit many pagans converted to
Christianity under the powerful
preaching of
Muhammad before he died he gave his
followers the Quran which in its
original uncorrupted form was simply an
Arabic translation of the New Testament
we can still see remnants of
Christianity even in the corrupt version
of the Quran that Muslims have today
that's why Jesus is so unique ique even
in the corrupted Quran even in the
corrupted Quran Jesus is the word of
Allah Jesus is a spirit proceeding from
Allah Jesus was born of a virgin Jesus
could create life and give sight to the
Blind and heal the lepers and raise the
dead Jesus is the Messiah and even the
corrupted Quran tells Christians to
judge by the gospel let the people of
the Gospel judge by what God God hath
revealed therein if any do fail to judge
by the light of what God hath revealed
they are no better than those who
Rebel so if the Quran was originally a
Christian book what
happened well there was a villain an
evil deceptive Pagan named utman who
hated Christianity and who didn't know
Muhammad and who worshiped Allah one of
the many Pagan deities of
Arabia after Muhammad died U decided to
destroy everything Muhammad had worked
so hard to accomplish the Diabolical uan
realized that the best way to destroy
Muhammad's work would be to become a
wolf in sheep's clothing and to
infiltrate the Christian Community in
Arabia so he pretended to be a Christian
and his deception was so convincing that
he eventually Rose to a position of
leadership once he was in charge uthman
ordered all of the Christians in Arabia
to hand over their copies of the Quran
I.E their copies of the Arabic
translation of the New Testament uthman
then rewrote the Quran turning it into a
book that denies the core teachings of
Christianity and he forced the
Christians of Arabia to believe in his
corrupted
Quran Muslim historians remembered
whatman did although even that story was
corrupted as we read in sah Al bukari
4987 Usman sent to every Muslim Province
one copy of what they had copied their
new thoroughly corrupt version of the
Quran and ordered that all the other
quranic materials the true original
Christian Quran whether written in
fragmentary manuscripts or whole copies
be
burnt so the Islam that Muslims believe
in today isn't the religion that
Muhammad preached Muhammad preached
submission to Jesus Christ uthman
corrupted this message by claiming that
Allah is the only true God and that
Jesus was a mere prophet of Allah he did
this in order to degrade Jesus and to
keep people from believing in
Christianity the religion of Muhammad
and that's how Muhammad's powerful
Christian message was transformed into
anti-christian propaganda by a wicked
Pagan
deceiver now how can Muslims refute my
theory they can't appeal to the Quran
since the Quran of today was corrupted
byman nor can they appeal to the Hadith
or the S literature or the commentaries
since all of these were written after
the time
ofman Muslims can't even say thatman was
one of Muhammad's companions since I
hereby declare thatman simply wrote
himself into Muhammad's life to help
establish his own
authority isnad criticism is irrelevant
since later isnad critics were under the
influence of uthman's false
teachings I conclude that Muhammad
preached Orthodox Christianity and that
utman was the true founder of what's now
called
Islam perhaps we should start referring
to Islam as U manism since it comes from
mman if any Muslims would like to debate
my theory I would be happy to defend my
claim that Muhammad was a devout
Christian all I'll need to do is use the
exact same methods that we've seen used
by zachar Nik and Ahmed D and shabir Ali
and Muhammad hijab and so many others
what better way to twist and distort
history than by using the methods that
Muslim Debaters use to twist and distort
the history of Jesus so how can Muslims
respond when I say that Muhammad was a
devout
Christian the only possible response
here from Muslims would be to reject the
methodology I just used to claim that
Muhammad was was a devout Christian
they'd have to say David it's silly and
irrational to throw out facts of History
by asserting that someone corrupted all
of the
evidence but how can they say this when
it's exactly what they do with
Jesus the historical facts about Jesus
don't line up with Islam so the
historical facts must have been changed
by Paul Fine the historical facts about
Muhammad don't line up with Christianity
so the historical facts about Muhammad
must have been changed
byman see how easy this
is if you want to steal everyone else's
guy we can steal your guy even though we
really really don't want your guy so
spread the word Christians Muhammad was
a devout Christian whose life and
teachings were corrupted by the Pagan
uthman there's absolutely nothing
Muslims can say or do to prove otherwise
without thoroughly undermining their own
methodology does all of this sound
ridiculous to you my Muslim friends does
the mental gymnastics routine I just
performed seem like a
joke well then now you know how we feel
when we have to sit here day after day
week after week month after month year
after year listening to you do the exact
same thing with Jesus Jus and Paul and
the Bible
[Music]